hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
section two of chapter three of pier
does philosophy is a way of life is
called learning to dialogue
and it focuses primarily on socrates and
plato but really what he has to say
here runs throughout the notion of
philosophy as a way of life
and specifically the spiritual
exercises the matrices of spiritual
exercises
in ancient philosophy that he's
concentrating on
in this this chapter and so you know it
makes sense that we
would talk about socrates because he's
so absolutely central
in early early ancient philosophy in the
west he says that the figure of socrates
causes the practice of spiritual
exercises to emerge
into western consciousness for this
figure was
and has remained the living call to
awaken our
moral consciousness and he and then he
goes on he says
we ought not forget that this call
sounded forth within a specific form
that of dialogue and it's worth
reminding ourselves that
plato is not the only person to have
written socratic dialogues dialogues
that are you know recording in some
sense very often with some some
modifications
we we think the things that socrates
actually
said and asked and engaged in with with
interlocutors
xenophon we we certainly have plenty of
his material
as well but we know that others wrote
dialogues even
you know to such a degree that there
were quibbles about which of them were
genuine and which ones
weren't if we look at diogenes liertes
plato is the largest body of these that
we have
and you know a little bit later in this
section
adobe is going to say the borderline
between socratic and platonic dialogue
is impossible to delimit the platonic
dial
is always socratic in inspiration
because it's an intellectual and in the
last analysis of spiritual
exercise so it's not as if we can
neatly extricate the real socrates from
plato's socrates or anything like that
we don't need
to because in part we're looking at what
people made of socrates
and that's that's what's what's really
particularly important
now in the socratic dialogue what a doe
stresses as absolutely central
and i think he's dead on with this is
saying that
the socratic dialogue is not just what
is
talked about but who is talking
the characters matter the way that they
engage with each other
matters it's not as if we have to say
well
we learn everything about the history of
these characters and then we import that
wholesale
into here because plato is of course you
know engaging in some
literary uh interpretation of them
but the way that they talk the the
things that they're willing
to think about and not think about prime
example of this
would be looking at say
the meno in which meno himself who's a
friend of socrates
and who at a certain point is like man i
don't i don't know what i'm talking
about i've talked about virtue
so much before socrates it's like you
took my brain away he talks about him as
stinging him and paralyzing him
he is willing to learn he wants to know
what's you know going on he wants to see
if socrates can help fill him in
and he also is willing to say oh man
i don't know what i thought i knew if we
contrast that to the young man who would
later on bring socrates up on on capital
charges
anitus and his engagement in the
dialogue he shows himself
as a different sort of character
threatening socrates at the very end in
a
prescient way right so that's a very
important thing not just what's talked
about but who is talking
what kind of person they are now i think
that ado goes a little bit far
in telling us that in a socratic
dialogue socrates interlocutor
doesn't learn anything in socrates
there's no intention of teaching
him anything he repeats that the only
thing he knows is that he does not know
anything
um you know that's there in some of the
dialogues but i think that's a bit of a
overstatement there if you read you know
socratic or platonic dialogues you do
see socrates in his interlocutor at many
points saying
well we know this at least right and we
know this at least we just don't know
what courage is or what virtue is or
whether it can be
taught or these sorts of questions but
there's a lot of ancillary
knowledge that's floating around and
you know socrates is doing some covert
teaching you could say in in some
respect
certainly at least by the idea of
jarring people's memories
and guiding them towards you know
bringing things
out of the depth of whatever
unconsciousness into consciousness
there is a very important effect though
that ado signals which is that of
calling people's attention
to themselves in ways that
then prep them for being able to do
philosophy like he says
like an indefatigable horsefly socrates
harassed as interlocutors with questions
which
put themselves into question forcing
themselves to pay attention to
and to take care of themselves
right and he says socrates mission
consisted in inviting his contemporaries
to examine their conscience
and to take care for their inner
progress and you know there's a lot of
descriptions about
what happens when this takes place um
you know mino
uh thinking about oh man i've been
talking about virtue this whole time
i guess i don't know what it is i really
need to
attend to that some of them are a little
bit more dense like euthyphro
does seem to be a bit puzzled but has no
problem going off to
you know bring the lawsuit against his
his father for
the death of a slave even though he's
going to be considered impeached
as a result some become hostile with
socrates
but many of them are willing to at least
realize that things are not as good as
they ought to be so
in plato's symposium prime example
alcibiades
describes the effect made on him by
dialogues with socrates
saying that he left him in such a state
of mind i felt he simply couldn't go on
living the way that i did
he makes me admit that while i'm
spending my time on politics i'm
neglecting all the things that are
crying for attention to myself so
so dialogue has the potential when
people are being genuine in it
of really you know bringing people's
attention
to where they currently are which may be
uncomfortable for them
adult goes on to say that socratic
dialogue can be understood as a communal
spiritual practice now isn't that an
interesting way
to talk about it engaging in dialogue
itself
is a spiritual practice it's one
that of course as we're going to see a
little bit later on
really depends on the interlocutor you
can't have dialogue with everybody
and you can also have dialogue with
yourself and you can also
dialogue with other people's dialogues
and this is where we come to talking
about plato just before that though he
says
in a socratic dialogue the interlocutors
are invited to participate in such inner
spiritual exercises
as examination of conscience and
attention to themselves
they're invited to comply with the
dictum know thyself
and what does that mean a dose says that
knowing yourself
invites us to establish a relation of
the self to the self
which constitutes the foundation of
every spiritual exercise now why is that
because
spiritual exercises are things that we
do
on and to and with ourselves
we're not doing them to somebody else
that's like making somebody else do
exercises that's not ourselves doing
exercise and so dialogues
can be understood as occasions for
getting people to to actually
do that sort of thing which are often
uncomfortable even
painful and frustrating
now he goes on and he tells us
platonic dialogues are model exercises
they're models in that they're not
transcriptions of real dialogues but
literary compositions
which present an ideal dialogue and at
that point you might say oh well
you know then wouldn't it be better just
have the real dialogues
real is always better than ideal no
there's something gained in the process
plato's dialogues allow us to
be involved with you know you could say
sit at the feet of socrates but socrates
is not a guru right
socrates is somebody who allows us into
the conversations of plato
aiding him to you know look at what's
being said and to think about how it
applies to ourselves
and our situation and to be ourselves
called into question and also at certain
points to say
wait a second socrates that's a bad
argument right
so there's a lot that that it makes
possible he says
they're exercises precisely insofar as
there's dialogues
these are an itinerary of the thought
whose route is traced by the constantly
maintained accord
between question and respondents a
little bit later
he tells us that within a platonic
dialogue
there's a lot of things that the modern
reader often doesn't have patience with
he says all the circles detours endless
divisions digressions and subtleties
which make the modern reader of plato's
dialogues
so uncomfortable are destined to make
ancient readers and interlocutors travel
a specific path thanks to these detours
with a great deal of effort one rob's
names definitions visions and sensations
against one another
one spends a long time in the company
these questions one lives with them
until the light blazes forth so the act
of actually
reading and thinking through platonic
dialogues is
spiritual exercise is it not
now there's two other really key things
that come out of this discussion of
dialogue in adobe
one of them has to do with the relation
of oneself with oneself and by engaging
in dialogue with others
according to ado we learn to engage
in dialogue internally and this is
central for spiritual exercises he says
going a little bit back he says if we
can trust the portrait
sketched by plato and aristophanes
socrates master of dialogue with others
was also a master of dialogue
with himself and therefore a master of
the practice of spiritual exercises now
let's pause on that for a moment
why would being a master of dialogue
with yourself
be equivalent to being a master of
spiritual exercises
because spiritual exercises are not
something
that you just get passively from
somebody else
and then jump to it and you know think
the things that you're supposed to think
or say the things that you're supposed
to say
or do the things that you're supposed to
do they are you
using whatever you want to call it your
will your faculty of choice your
pro-eurasis
on itself on you to make yourself
do certain things this is why you know
we for co called these technologies of
the self i think quite rightly
you are using techniques that that apply
to
yourself and a lot of that part of what
i do really brings out quite
successfully
a lot of that involves linguistic or
cognitive
aspects you talk to yourself
these days we have the term used in
therapy
self-talk usually we're bringing that up
in light of
oh knock out the negative self-talk
about oh i'm such a loser i'll never be
able to give a good speech
dialogue is indeed self dialogue with
oneself
is self talk could be negative could be
positive
it could be interrogative it could be
all sorts of things
socrates is a master at that and in
order to be good at spiritual exercises
you do have to have sort of an interior
not monologue
dialogue with yourself so
you know we've got all sorts of examples
of this
adult goes on and says meditation the
practice of dialogue with oneself seems
to have held a place of honor among
socrates disciples
when antisthenes founder of the cynics
school was asked what profit he derived
from philosophy he replied
the ability to converse with myself
the intimate connection between dialogue
with others and dialogue with oneself
is profoundly significant only he
who is capable of a genuine encounter
with the other
is capable of an authentic encounter
with himself and the converse is equally
true
this is an absolutely important point
and this leads us to the second thing
the dimension of the interlocutor
dialogue is not
dialogue if it's merely monologue
talking ant
right and so at a certain point there
has to be
engagement between the people so some
you know where you have passages where
it's socrates saying something
and then it's glaucon saying wow
socrates that's so clever wow that's
great yes indeed socrates
it's not dialogue at that point is it
there has to be some you know
engagement with an interlocutor who
could call you into question who could
say i don't buy into it who could walk
away
from the encounter there has to be this
capacity for risk and that's what keeps
dialogues like he says from becoming a
theoretical dogmatic expose
and forces it to be a concrete practical
exercise
the point is not to set forth a doctrine
rather to guide the interlocutor towards
a determinate
mental attitude this is a combat
amicable
but real and then this is very important
there has to be an engagement of the
self with the other
you could say using contemporary terms
that this is an existential
engagement an engagement of the meaning
of one's existence where one commits
one's self
socrates does this all the time and he
does it in the ways that he presents his
views he also does it in how he talks
with others we come back to
who is talking i want to know
not just what you think but how it
applies to
your life are there discrepancies
between
these sorts of things or is everything
on
on point addo says
uh in spiritual exercises we must let
ourselves be changed
in our point of view attitudes and
convictions um
so we have to be open to that sort of
thing there has to be a possibility
of conversion we have to be motivated by
a desire for truth not just a desire to
be right
not just a desire to win not just a
desire to have things
easy for ourselves or secure or
something
like that at the very end of this
section he says
as a dialectical exercise the platonic
dialogue corresponds exactly to a
spiritual exercise
the dialogue guides the interlocutor and
the reader towards conversion
and this has to be motivated by
a desire for truth he says in fact the
dialectical effort is
an ascent in common towards the truth
and towards the good
which every soul pursues and then he
says furthermore in plato's view
every dialectical exercise because it's
an exercise of pure thought
subject to the demands of the logos
turns the soul away from the sensible
world and allows it to convert itself
towards
the good does that apply to every other
philosophical conception no but a lot of
this
will apply not just to the platonist
school of philosophy but to other
socratically inspired
schools as well and can go on down to
the present you might say
you